if you help me yes Queen
uh-oh uh-oh it's off to work we go and
we can't imagine ah okay you guys doing
cheese he's my dog yes stop - my dogs
make out he was a king with his ass so
bad
what y'all got bad asses I'm Hercules
[ __ ] yes indeed
have you ever heard the wolf cry to the
blue corn chips
mmm Keith look I'm in around you are not
in the building anymore
oh you're out poking all this don't look
at why we do not put betray in it think
of Batman movies made when no no one is
still away with detail are you hero
Neverland deserves
but not the one it needs right now that
look in your furnace so familiar gun
shut up Eugene pregnant
sick of swimmin ready to stand me my
fins are swollen and I want some clams
don't you want to be where the people
are no I want to be on the ocean floor
Halloween Halloween what this window
road up ahead and you bow bow I'll bid
you do dribble with your hotel Sylvia
Matson horsing really young man with all
the force of a great typhoon I was the
type of - I've got video
you know with me oh the doors are locked
please ducktales woo
life is like a Burger King it's a duck
burn a whole new world
every mamasan winner what I thought you
knew that's why we're such billowy pants
cuz of my diaper oh my god get off my
carpet you don't you just do it right
now
no sorry call me no I won't take pajamas
painting ones on the bottom paper jobs
painting was on the bottom if the jobs
name was on the bottom and pajamas baby
ones on the fun you guys do it stop it
throwing my dog's kiss so weird but it's
not you can't you let it go it doesn't
sound like that at all no knows every
word to the song and then see it's
really well but frozen is my favorite
let it go what no no come on guys come
on let it go by course one by one till
you shall get off my lawn huh here's the
middle of the night and on my table I
eat here salad and goood a chicken to
pull a bibbity Boppity boo put them
together and what do you got please let
me into the group donkey Oh No salad and
Gouda chicken - boo - boo boo love it oh
you
Andy's coming oh oh what oh I swear I
heard something was wrong with me